thank him for delivering us from all the
trials and tribulations of 2021
and i hope that we have made a decision
to leave the grudges of 221 in 221
and enter into 222 with a different
mindset all together it is with that
mindset in mind that our subject is
weapons of war what did i say
weapons of war
[Music]
i will bless the lord at all times his
praise shall continually be in my mouth
my soul shall make her boast in the lord
the humble shall hear thereof and be
glad
o magnify the lord with me
and let us exalt his name together
i sought the lord and he heard me
and delivered me from all my fears
they looked unto him and were lightened
and their faces were not ashamed
this poor man cried and the lord heard
him and saved him out of all his
troubles
the angel of the lord encampeth wronged
about them that fear him
and deliver of them
oh taste and see
that the lord is good
blessed is the man
that trusteth in him
god is good
and all the time
happy sabbath everyone
happy new year
and i say that for those of you in the
building
and to those of you connecting via
whatever electronic means of connection
you have youtube facebook zoom whatever
it is we're grateful you're with us this
is the very first sabbath of the new
year and someone sent me a text saying
what a blessing to have the new year
begin on the holy day that's one good
reason to try to live an entirely holy
life
in this new year i thank god for life
and i'm sure you do as well
thank him for delivering us from all the
trials and tribulations of
2021. and i hope that we have made a
decision to leave the grudges of 221
in 221
and enter into 222 with a different
mindset all together it is with that
mindset in mind that our subject is
weapons of war what did i say
weapons of war before i proceed
is there any one president who is not a
seventh-day adventist merch your hand
all right i believe they are online
those worshipping with us who are not
seventh-day adventists
if that is the case thank you very much
for taking the time to fellowship with
us and may the lord bless you so
copiously that you will desire to
fellowship with us again when i say us i
mean the seventh-day adventist
congregation
i have some friends in nairobi who are
watching and around the world wherever
you are i can't begin to call names
thank you for connecting god bless you
god bless you beyond your imagination
all right
it is now
11 36 i'll release you before 12 30. i'm
quite sure
i hope that pleases you
before i since you said no you may
regret not saying yes it pleases us
if you don't need this as a bible please
make sure it's turned off let me check
mine so you don't have to say to me
physician heal thyself
all right it's off
i'll ask you also while i'm speaking
pray for me
and simply say lord put
your words in that man's mouth
this is a very serious request while
you're speaking the devil can just twist
your tongue and you may say the right
thing the wrong way
or you may say the right thing
the wrong time are you following me you
know jesus told the disciples i have yet
many things to say unto you
excuse me but you cannot bear them now
it's very interesting god is so precise
god may require the speaker to say
something
at a certain time in the message because
that's when someone listening is ready
to receive it and so i need you to pray
lord put your words in that man's mouth
and may lord grant me the humility to
listen to the spirit when he tells me
say this or don't say that favor number
three
think as you listen
isaiah 1 18 come now let us do what
reason together saith the lord
we serve a reasonable god and i'm very
grateful for that
the devil is not reasonable at all
but god is
let us pray
father in heaven
we come before you in the name of jesus
a name you always accept
we thank you dey god that we're alive
we thank you for bringing us safely
through 2021
and have ushered us on the doorstep of
2022.
father we know not lie what lies in the
year we don't know what lies five
minutes from now
and so they god we ask you to take us by
the hand
guide us step by step dear god as we
continually surrender ourselves to you
that you may guide us as unerringly as
you guided the israelites through the
wilderness
if we've sinned against you forgive us i
pray particularly me
i humble myself before you lay god
and i ask you in the name of your son my
savior
speak through me father
hide me behind the cross that you may be
seen
and heard i offer myself to you as an
instrument in the hands of a master
musician do with me as you will
bless everyone listening whether in this
building or online day god grant them
comprehension as the words of truth are
presented
if anyone under the sound of my voice
has contracted covet 19 in the name of
jesus christ the great physician
healed those persons father 100
those who suffered the loss of loved
ones comfort them father and reassured
them that the day is coming when death
shall be no more death shall actually
die
father bless anyone listening who is not
a seventh-day adventist touch that
person in a very special way and put a
double blessing on their children now
their god we commit this service to your
glory bless not only us
but wherever your people are worshiping
now bless them father let your presence
be sensed and felt
in jesus name we pray let god's people
say amen and amen
romans chapter 12
weapons of war
romans 12.
we read from verse 17. and i read from
the king james version of the bible
romans 12
recompense to no man evil for evil
provide things honest in the sight of
all men
if it be possible
as much as life in you
live peaceably
with all men
and under the circumstances in our
country live peaceably with the
government let me say it again
if
it be possible
as much as lieth in you
not the other person
live peaceably
with all men
dearly beloved
avenge not yourselves but rather give
place unto wrath for it is written
vengeance is mine i will repay saith the
lord
therefore
if thine enemy hunger
tell me
feed him
if he thirsts
give him drink
for in so doing thou shalt keep calls of
fire on his head
read 21 with me
be not overcome
of evil
but overcome evil with good
let me read that again
be not
overcome
of evil
but overcome evil
with good let us take a look at evil
genesis 2 verse 9
evil does not always mean what we think
it means in the bible
genesis chapter 2 verse 9 our subject
weapons of war
and out of the ground made the lord god
to grow every tree that's pleasant to
the sight and good for food the tree of
life also in the midst of the garden and
the tree of knowledge of good and evil
this is our introduction to the word
evil in the bible and in verse 16 and 17
the bible says also genesis 2 and the
lord god commanded the man saying
of every tree of the garden thou mayest
freely eat
but of the tree of the knowledge of good
and evil thou shalt not eat of it for in
the day thou eat as thereof thou shall
surely die we have a connection between
evil and death
involvement in evil leads to death
actually evil which is sin has death in
it wherefore as by one man sin entered
into the world and death by sin sin
evil wickedness transgression iniquity
they have death in them sins are nothing
more than slices of death
and so god said in the day thou eatest
thereof thou shalt surely die avoid evil
genesis 6 reading verse 5 as we continue
weapons of war
and god saw that the wickedness of man
was great in the earth the word
wickedness there is the same hebrew word
for evil and so we have the dark side or
the darkest side of evil but evil can
also mean something else
go to genesis 19.
we'll read from verse 15
of genesis 19.
thank you
you have genesis 19 you read from
philistine as you look for it let me ask
god again one more time father put your
words in my mouth on the spirit of
christ in my heart in jesus name i ask
amen
and when the morning arose then the men
hastened a lot saying arise take thy
wife and thy two daughters which are
here lest thou be consumed in the
iniquity of the city and while he
lingered
the men laid hall upon his hand and upon
the hand of his wife
and upon the hand of his two daughters
the lord being merciful unto him and
they brought him forth and set him
without the city this is god trying to
save lot from the impending doom for on
sodom and gomorrah and it came to pass
when they had brought them forth abroad
that he said escape for thy life
look not behind thee neither stay thou
in all the plains escape to the mountain
lest thou be consumed and lord said unto
them oh not so my lord behold thy
servant have found grace in thy sight
listen to lord now and thou has
magnified thy mercy which thou has shown
unto me in saving my life now listen to
how the verse ends and i cannot escape
to the mountain and finish that verse
lest some evil take me and i die now the
word evil there does not mean sin it
simply means a calamity perhaps on the
way to the mountain i may fall into a
well or i may be attacked by a wild
animal something unfortunate the word
evil there means a calamity
not something with a moral dimension to
it
when christ was caught in a storm that
storm was an evil are you following me a
landslide is an evil the typhoon that
devastated parts of the philippines a
couple of weeks ago that's an evil
the the floods that went through
tennessee i believe it was a couple of
months ago that's an evil the tornadoes
that destroyed so much of houses in
kentucky that's an evil there's a fire
now in boulder colorado that's an evil
not a sin
it is in this context we must read
isaiah 45 verse 7. i need to deal with
that quickly as we continue weapons of
war isaiah 45 verse 7
people have come to me with that verse
saying ah god commits sin it really
irritates me when they do that because
they do not understand god
i do what form
the light
and make
darkness
and create darkness i do what
make peace and create evil i the lord do
all these sin what does god mean by i
create evil god says i can send
calamities god does not create sin
who sent the flood god who sent fire on
sodom and gomorrah god who sent the ten
plagues god they were evils not sin so
god is saying i can send calamity as now
if you look at the verse carefully if
you look at the first part i
form the light and create darkness so we
have two opposites
are you following me now the other pair
also is also two opposites i make peace
and create evil so evil there is really
the opposite of peace in that verse
am i talking to myself or are you with
me
and so evil there means something that
disrupts your peace
all right
but the evil in romans 12 21
be not overcome of evil
but overcome evil with good does not
refer to hurricane you can't overcome a
hurricane with good are you following me
all right it means something morally
wrong
but we're called by god to overcome evil
how when we have a clue therefore if thy
enemy hunger
feed him
if he thirsts
give him drink
we see the hints of opposites hunger
should be met with
food
thirst should be met with drink now
let's look at a parallel passage matthew
5 reading from verse 43 to get more
light what is a parallel passage is a
bible passage that explains another
similar passage
because parallel things run
side by side
a parallel passage matthew 5 reading
from verse 43 our subject weapons of war
it's 11 48.
those of you online i hope you're still
with us
you have heard that it hath been said
thou shalt love thy neighbor and hate
thine enemy
but i say unto you
let me pause on that again and digress
you have heard what the government said
but i say unto you
you have heard what your boss said
you've heard what nasa is saying by
sending a telescope to discover how the
world was formed but i say unto you in
the beginning god created the heaven and
the earth are you with me we must our
final step must be but i say
you've heard that your friend said if
you want to be cool smoke some drugs but
i say this temple is the home of the
holy spirit
you've heard that it hath been said
thou shalt love thy neighbor and hit
thine enemy but i say unto you
read with me now love your enemies
that's love bless them that curse you
that's blessed do good to them that hate
you that's do good and pray for them
which despitefully use you and persecute
you we have
love
bless
do good
and pray
do you see that
we have love
we have bless
we have do good
we have pray
in response to
enemies
curse
hate
despitefully use and persecute
what's your subject
weapon of war weapons of war
now jesus says
love your enemies
our natural condition
is to hate our enemies
early in that chapter said and whosoever
shall smite thee on their right she
finish it for me turn to him the other
also the christ is speaking to converted
people
the sermon on the mount was for the
disciples
the multitudes overheard but if you
listen to the read the bible carefully
matthew 5 1 says and seeing the
multitudes he went up into a mountain
and when he was set his disciples came
unto him and he opened his mouth and
taught them but the multitude was
overheard but the sermon on the mount is
not for unsaved people
it's for children of god
and he's god christ says to the child of
god whosoever shall smite thee on thy
right cheek
turn to him the other also in this
context we read bless love your enemies
bless them that curse you do good to
them that hate you and pray for them we
despitefully use you and persecute you
and so we have love bless do good pray
that is what has to come out of you
in response to what comes out of the
other person which is enemy or hatred
cursing
you know hatred
spitefully using you and persecuting you
good bless
pray comes out of
us according to god
hate
enemy persecute despiteful use comes out
of the prosecutors now
we have two different sources of two
different things now let's go to mark
seven
our subject
weapons of war
the bible tells us how to overcome evil
do you have matthew mark 7 we'll read
from verse 14
has anyone said lord put your words in
that man's mouth here
ah god bless you god bless you all right
and when you call all the people unto
him he said unto them
hearken unto me and understand how many
of them
every one of you
i like that jesus tells the multitude i
expect every one of you to understand
hearken to me and understand every one
of you there's nothing from without a
man that entering hint into him can
defile him but the things which come out
of him those are there that defy the man
now we have to look at that closely and
microscopically
jesus says there is nothing from where
without a man that entering into him can
defile him
now let's keep our minds on matthew
chapter 5 again without going back there
bless them that
curse you
the person curses you it enters into
your head are you with me
what does it not do
it doesn't defile
there's nothing from without a man
that entering into him can defy him
but those things which come out of him
but the things which come out of him
those are there that defile the man
is a very very powerful principle
now why is that
let's keep reading
if any men have ears to hear let him
hear and when he was entered into the
house from the people his disciples
asked him concerning the parable and he
said unto them are ye so without
understanding do we not perceive that
whatsoever thing from without entrance
into a man it cannot defy him now he
tells them why in verse 19 why because
it entereth not where
into his heart now out of the abundance
of the
the mouth speaketh on all actions
perceived from the heart
that's why christ changes this
christ said it does not enter into the
heart it enters into the belly referring
of course to unclean foods
by the way unclean foods do not defile
us
the decision to disobey god is the
defilement
uh you missed it it's my fault let me
try again
a pork chop
in and of itself is not a sin are you
with me a decision to eat it is a sin
because it violates god's dietary laws
is that clear and so it is not the pork
chop coming in
it is the decision from within going out
it entereth not into the heart mark 7
verse 19 but into the ballet and goes
out into the draft purging all meets now
verse 20 of mark 7 and he said that
which cometh out of the man
that defileth the man
okay
having said that let us go back to
matthew 5
quickly
quickly quickly quicker than that
matthew 5
43 again
you have heard it have been said thou
shalt love thy neighbor and hit that
enemy but i say unto you love your
enemies bless them that hate you
pray do good to them that
bless them that love your enemies bless
them that curse you do good to them that
hate you and pray for them which
despitefully use you and persecute you
now read 45 with me that ye may be the
children of your father
which is in heaven
not children of the world
when christ prayed for the disciples in
john 17 verse 14 verse 16 he said they
are not of the world even as i am not of
the world god is saying if you are a
child of heaven you bless those who
curse you you love your enemies question
for you this is african-american church
largely
should you love members of the clan say
yes or no quickly
did that hurt
does the bible call us to love them
yes
now let us go against culture and
that's why a child of god is a different
creature altogether
different altogether when jesus lives on
this earth the people said what manner
of man is this
that ye may be the children of your
father which is in heaven for he maketh
his son to rise on the evil and on the
good and send it reign on the just and
on the unjust now listen to verse 46 and
47 for if you love them which love you
what reward have he
do not even the
republicans the same
now that's a very embarrassing statement
let me show you why
jesus said
if you only love those who like you
you are no different
from the publicans
but who were the publicans
let's take a look at republicans go to
matthew 9.
we read 10 and 11 weapons of war
3 minutes to 12.
you have matthew 9
10 and 11
and it came to pass as jesus sat at meat
in the house behold many publicans and
sinners came and sat down with him and
his disciples and when the pharisees saw
it they said unto his disciples why
eateth your master with whom publicans
and sinners sinners there does not mean
someone who made a mistake it means
someone's whose lifestyle is wickedness
are you following me now republicans are
classed with sinners
in that verse
go to matthew 18.
jesus says you know different
republicans we have to look at publicans
matthew 18 let's read from verse 15 a
very familiar passage moreover if thy
brother shall trespass against thee go
and tell him his fault between thee and
him alone
he shall if he shall hear thee thou has
gained thy brother but if he will not
hear thee then take with the one or two
more that in the mouth of two or three
witnesses every word may be established
and if you neglect
he shall neglect to hear them tell it
unto the church but if you neglect to
hear the church finish that verse with
me now let him be what
as a heathen and uh publica now in
matthew 9 the publicans are clashed with
whom
sinners in matthew 18 they clash with
whom even the unbelievers let's go to
matthew 21
there's three chapters to the right
from verse 28 on jesus sells the parable
of a man who had two sons he told one go
to the vineyard and work he said i won't
go then he went he tells the other one
go he said i'm going but he didn't go
you know that story in verse 31
the second half of that verse jesus says
unto them verily i say unto you
the publicans come on
and the harlots go into the kingdom of
god before you now in matthew 9
publicans are class with whom
sinners in matthew 18 they clash with
whom the heathen the unbelievers in
matthew 21 they clash with whom harlots
now gee keep this in mind and go back to
matthew 5 verse 46
for if you love them which loves you
what reward have he do not even the
publicans the same
and if you salute your brethren only
verse 47 what do we more than others who
are the others the publicans do not even
the public console
then you begin to understand why jesus
said earlier in that chapter except your
righteousness shall exceed the
righteousness of the scribes and
pharisees god calls us to a standard
that the world cannot understand
you know better
than republican now you're vegetarian
you're well-dressed yes
but you're just a vegetarian publican
most demon-possessed people look normal
are you listening to me
most demon-possessed people look
normal
all right what have we said
we're supposed to overcome evil how
with good
we saw an example of good
love your enemies love bless them that
curse you blessed do go to them that
hate you do good pray so you bless you
love you bless you do good that's good
these are the weapons
of our warfare
we know from ii corinthians 10 4 for the
weapons our warfare are not carnal but
mighty through god to the pulling down
of strong they're not carnal meaning
they're not of a man-made nature that's
what carnal means in that verse doesn't
mean sinful it means earthly
but the weapons we are to use a
spiritual
we have an example of evil we have
enemies
we have curse
we have persecute we have despitefully
use
we have hate now all of that comes from
the enemy
and because that makes that person evil
because jesus said evil comes from
inside out not from the outside in but
if i
retaliate
are you with me
now retaliation is is attitudinal
ping-pong you hit the ball and i hit it
even harder
are you with me now jesus is saying
virtually if you
respond to hatred with hatred
you are no different
from the person
who hated you first
so you have joined the ranks
jesus was hated and he loved what did he
say on the cross to those who were
crucifying him father
forgive them when stephen was being
stoned before the stoning ended what was
his last words lord
lay not this sin to their church
paul was abandoned when he was first
tried second timothy chapter 4 verse 16
at my first answer no man stood with me
but all men forsook me i pray god it may
not be put to their charge
different attitude altogether
when evil is done to us the bible's
prescription is the weapon to fight it
is to respond with the very opposite
that is not as easy as it sounds that's
why the bible says in second timothy 6
verse 12
fight the good fight of faith
let me take your mind it is one step
higher or lower
this is not the evil that's our greatest
danger what people do to us
listen to romans 12 21 again be not
overcome of evil
but overcome evil with good
the evil that really threatens our
salvation is not persecution from people
because jesus says
nothing coming from the outside can
defile
no amount of hatred from the world can
defile you no amount of the mistreatment
from your enemy can defile you the
filemaker does not come from the outside
in the final comes from the inside
out let's go to mark seven again
our subject weapons of war mark seven is
four minutes after twelve
do you have mark chapter seven
let's read from verse seven
if i'm going to say amen
and he said
that which cometh out of the man that
defile of the man
for from within
out of the heart of man proceed evil
thoughts adulteries fornications murders
theft
covetousness wickedness
deceit lasciviousness an evil eye
blasphemy pride foolishness all these
evil things come from where
from within and
defile now if no one ever persecutes you
is there evil from within
yes
if no one ever curses you and your
family is there evil within yes and so
when we read romans 12 21 be not
overcome with evil but overcome evil
with good we must rise above simply
persecution from others which the bible
calls evil and consider that the most
dangerous evil is not what people do to
us but what we do to god
now this must also be overcome
with good
are you saying amen because you're nicer
because you're following me
there is evil with us the bible says
because the carnal mind is enmity
against god for it is not if satan died
tonight we'd sin tomorrow
we sin tonight
the devil is the instigator of sin
we are the
perpetrators of sin
i'm not defending the devil not by any
means i'm not
but we need to be intelligent
the devil cannot make anyone sin
the devil invites and we have to rsvp
god can't make anyone do right he has to
encourage and we have to do the same
thing and so our sins are our doing not
the doing of the devil temptation is his
work sometimes we create our own
temptations
and so there is an evil in us that must
be overcome and as verily as we overcome
evil from without with good we must
overcome evil within with good and what
is that good let's go to psalm 100 verse
5.
psalm 100 verse 5 are subject weapons of
war
do you have
that for the lord
is what
good
let's go to uh exodus 34 reading verses
five on six
this is god coming down to respond to
moses's request
show me thy glory in chapter 33 god is
coming down to show him what he really
needs to see he want to see god's face
god will show him his character god does
not always give us what we want he gives
us what is good for us somebody say amen
and the lord descended in the cloud and
stood with him there and proclaimed the
name of the lord and the lord passed by
before him and proclaimed the lord the
lord merciful and gracious
long-suffering what does that next
statement say abundant in
goodness
is a divine quality
are you following me go to romans 7.
romans
7. let's read verse 12.
romans chapter 7 verse 12 our subject
weapons of war
more people leave the church because of
hard feelings and because of bad
theology
it's easier to cure cancer than the girl
someone whose feelings have been hurt
it may we forget favors we never forget
insults
romans 7 12
wherefore the law is
holy and the commandment
holy come on just and good
the goodness
that is identified in romans 12 21 is at
his highest the very righteousness of
god which is seen in the way god acts
and it also seen in his law which was
lived out in the life of christ
if evil comes from within
it has to be stopped where
from within
it cannot be stopped from without if it
issues from within let me say that again
evil that is natural to us must be
stopped from within now how does god do
that i will put my law where in the
inward parts come on and write it away
on their hearts now as verily as the
holy ghost wrote the ten commandments in
exodus 34 so verily does he write them
on the fleshy tables of the heart now
where the law of god which is the
righteousness of god because god's law
is as sacred as god himself where the
law of
righteousness abides
sin
and evil as a lifestyle cannot abide
when god said and i will put enmity
between thee and the woman between thy
seed and her seed the only way to hate
sin
is to love
righteousness
and so god the father describes jesus
this way in hebrews 1 verse 9 thou has
loved righteousness and
hated iniquity you just have to do one
that is love righteousness and
automatically animosity for sin develops
and so proverbs 8 36 says all they that
hate me love death
and wisdom there refers to christ all
they that hate me automatically love
death what am i saying when the law of
god is written on the heart we
automatically hate sin
go to
mal not malachi yes malachi 2. go to
malachi 2 the last book of the old
testament
how many books in the old testament
quickly
how many of the new
all right our bible teacher is on the
ball
what book did i say
malachi what chapter
what verse
now read this verse carefully six
are you there
read with me if you have the king james
version the law of truth was where
in his mouth keep reading
and iniquity was not found in his lips
stop
fathers i continue speak to me god
please in jesus name i appeal to you
amen
let's read microscopically
the law
of truth was in his mouth
because of that read the next statement
iniquity
was not found
now what's the difference between lips
and mouth nothing
those two statements are saying
virtually the same thing it's like by
the word of the lord where the heavens
made and all the hosts of them by the
breath of his mouth same thing for he
speak it was done he commanded this so
fast same thing
the law of truth was in his mouth and
because the law of truth filled his
mouth iniquity was not found in his
mouth because iniquity cannot be found
where the lord dwells
so if the law dwells in here
what has to be evicted
iniquity
now
we may have
the church manual in here
and we thank god to church manual
you may have your textbooks in here
you may have the testimonies in here
the only antidote to evil
is to have the law of god in the heart
which is a very righteousness of god
be not
overcome of evil
overcome evil with good and there is no
higher goodness than the law of god
and as verily as that which cometh out
of the man defile of the man that which
cometh out also blesses the man
and so jesus says a good man out of the
good treasure bringing forth good things
and an evil man out of the evil treasure
bringing forth evil things whether good
or bad the source is the same our weapon
of warfare is the very standard of
righteousness by which jesus christ
lived
and so as you and i proceed through 2022
people on the job will hurt our feelings
people at home will hurt your feelings
people in the church will certainly hurt
your feelings
be not overcome of that evil
overcome evil
with good now try it
but there's a higher evil
because what people do to us does not
defile us why because it comes from the
outside in
it is what we do that brings the
defilement because we have a nature
that's not yet dead now if we're
converted it is subjugated it is under
the control of the spirit but not dead
and so that's the evil we must watch and
guard against paul says in romans are
not romans galatians 5 17 for the flesh
lusteth against the spirit and the
spirit against the flesh and these are
contrary one to the other there's a
constant battle but the victory is to
live in obedience to the law of god by
the indwelling power of christ
and so paul says to you and to me as i
wind down
i am crucified
with christ
nevertheless i live
now when you're crucified with christ
you crucify you've crucified retaliation
you've crucified getting back at people
you've crucified
all related to that
and what has come alive
is the selflessness of jesus christ and
so paul says i am crucified with christ
nevertheless i live yet not i but christ
liveth in me now go to matt go to john
chapter five let's see how christ liveth
in me go to john 5.
read verse 38 carefully
you have john 5
verse 38 read it very very carefully
christ dwelling in me says paul
you have not but you have not the love
of god where
abiding in you why
for him
[Music]
he come on
sent come on
you receive you believe not to receive
not and john is saying look
christ does not abide the word of god
does not abide in you why because you
have not received christ christ and the
word are in sap christ is the word
we receive christ
by receiving the word
and he hath not his word abiding in you
for him whom he have sent he received
not now listen to john 15 7 if you abide
in me and my words abide in you
if there'd be no sin there will still
have been the ten commandments
but somebody say amen
what's the whole duty of man
fair god and keep his command
will that continue in the new world yes
was that the way it was before sin yes
does that apply to angels yes now
if there'd be no sin there would have
been no bible
there would still have been
the law of god
dwelling here
when lucifer rebelled elohim says the
angels were shocked to find out there
was a law
because it was here they just kept it
natural there were surprised there was a
lot they just kept it naturally
as the world went on and on people
became more wicked more wicked abraham
and noah and shem and these guys did not
need a written law it was here but after
the egyptian bondage and years and years
of distance from god the jews had
forgotten not the jews he is right who
god was god had to come down actually
speak it because sin had multiplied god
had been forgotten that's why moses said
when i come to them and i tell them you
sent me what name will i give them
they've forgotten god the law had to be
given specifically
you have not the word of god abide in
you
for whom you've sent
him you receive not
you take the bible
you condense it into one summary
is the ten commandments
not even john 3 16
because if there had been no sin there
would have been no need
for john 3 16
but there's always a need for the law of
god
be not overcome
of evil
but overcome evil with good we looked at
two levels of evil what people do to us
and we discovered that does not defile
us
the evil that should concern us is the
evil that comes out of us but we have
the same warfare the same weapon
overcome that evil with good and the
highest level of good
is the goodness of god as expressed in
his holy law
in 2022
i am not concerned with what groups do
as i am with what individuals do
are you following me
it's a strange thing
if you
take your mind back to january 6
last year as unpleasant as that almost a
year now can you believe that
if you ask one individual you go by
yourself and riot
are you following me
he wouldn't have done it
put him in a crowd and he doesn't
you put one michigan fan in that stadium
watching a football game between
michigan ohio state michigan scores a
touchdown he's likely to just sit there
surround with 120 000 he jumps and
shouts are you following me
we are affected by the crowd god deals
with
individual
conviction does not require crowd
support
i'm talking to individuals ella white
writes mind character personality volume
2 page 423 paragraph 2 the gospel deals
with individuals and okay what your
mother does what are you doing
and so the my thrust is we need to make
individual decisions in this new year
how we will handle evil two levels what
people do to us that's the lower level
that does no spiritual damage
but the evil that comes out of us
and the answer is
be not overcome of evil
but overcome evil with good
and that goodness is a very quality of
god and god's righteousness his holiness
his goodness all of it is concentrated
in his law that is why the law of god
was not found in the outer court it was
not found in the holy place it was found
where in the most holy place which
represents glorification
how many of you will say with me today
father
help me
to overcome evil this year
with good can i see your hair
ah god bless you beyond your hopes and
dreams stand with me
and we'll pray before i pray are there
any prayer requests
yes that's right
the grady family yes grief does not
leave immediately
you know last week four people i know
passed away dick baron you may not
remember him you're too young to
remember him dick baron
tall fellow youth director from the gc
you know he called me a couple of months
ago and said randy skeet left a message
for me called me called me i hadn't
heard this man in 40 years since i was
broke with
i called him he said well you've blessed
my life i just want to contact you and
say hi and a few weeks later he was dead
it was very strange thing
a former professor of mine who had moved
to ghana clifford he passed
a passer for whom i spoke in this summer
eugene anthony
you mean he used to be you know uh
region he passed
and that one really hit me then of
course the grades have lost
but let me give you some good news god
is putting many of his people to sleep
before the storm breaks
remember revelation pronounces a
blessing on death in jesus blessed are
the dead which die in the lord so as we
grieve remember that god is not grieving
god is now he
he sees his servants and they can no
longer be tempted they can no longer
suffer they are secure because god in
his stubborn love has done what is
necessary to make sure they will be with
him he has put them to sleep
any of the prayer requests
yes in the back
sister copeland all right valerie you
said copeland okay yes
who's that
oh jody has surgery coming up okay yes
that's right
sister johnson pray for her okay all
right
anybody else yes sister brazil
say it for me
who's having surgery
oh okay
all right okay we pray you know ella
white writes i believe that when kellogg
conducted surgeries angels guided his
hands
so we last angels to guide the hands of
the surgeons and the spirit to guide
their minds because we're god's people
anybody else yes devi
yes yes yes yes brother ray all right
okay let's pray
our father in heaven we thank you today
god that your word contains the
prescription for victorious living
we are to overcome evil with good and
there is no higher good than your
character as expressed in your law
father
as we proceed through this new year let
us not be so concerned about what people
do to us
let us be concerned with what we do to
you
by the way we live and speak and think
in the name of jesus christ there god
forgive our shortcomings and grant us
that grace that power to so live that
you may say of us as you said of job has
thou considered my servant
father bless those who are ill but the
doug is having surgery jody as well we
ask you to be merciful you guide all the
professionals that will be performing
the procedures that all might be well
remember sister valerie remember the
request from sister wright and whatever
unspoken quest there may be in the name
of jesus christ father be generous be
graciously god and do for us what we
cannot do for ourselves now father as we
leave this church let us begin to apply
the weapons of warfare
bless not only us but wherever your
people are blessed and i pray in jesus
name let god's people say amen and amen
[Music]
you